okay so definitions of methodology let's
start with what is artificial
intelligence because this has changed
over history when AI first started back
in the 1970s it was really the attempt
to reproduce mental functions in a human
being by a computer but now that's not
necessarily the case there are various
approaches to AI and this is important
to remember you'll see deep learning
deep reinforcement learning all sorts of
different kinds of things in artificial
intelligence has to do with different
types of algorithms that are applied to
a particular problem almost all of the
time the artificial intelligence is
going to replace traditional yes/no
logic with some sort of a statistical
clustering or some sort of fuzzy logic
that doesn't exactly have just a pure
yes-or-no all the time it may but it
doesn't have to include an expert
representation meaning someone has
front-loaded it with a model based on an
experts knowledge of a particular
situation there are AI programs that
work that way there are others that are
basically advanced statistics one thing
that they all have though and this is a
definitional element of artificial
intelligence they all include some
element of machine learning so that the
the program repeats itself being applied
to new sets of data and as it continues
to work on solving the same problem
multiple times it gets better and better
at it so machine learning has to be
there for it to be called artificial
intelligence it's always useful to keep
this in mind because AI has become such
a hot topic one of the things that my
contacts in China tell me is that if you
can somehow work AI into the description
of your startup you can increase your
value
by about a hundred percent so make sure
it's really a I before you get into that
AI is really it's the right time for AI
not only has computing power become a
lot more powerful it's become a lot more
cheap and most AI programs require
access to very large amounts of data and
data storage has become both very
efficient and cheap without cloud
computing you probably could not have
artificial intelligence most of the time
because you really have to have access
to data on a scale that's not just going
to reside in one machine ai also has
been a great way to approach some
problems that are very difficult to do
in traditional kind of mathematical
analysis a problem with thousands of
variables a problem with all sorts of
kinds of strange distributions there was
a there's a little company that does
demand forecasting using AI and instead
of just a standard distribution of
expected outcomes they have a complete
set of different scenarios each of which
has its own probability distribution so
you can see that the number of variables
just multiplies this allowed them by the
way this company is called low CAD this
allowed them to do a great job of
improving the availability of spare
parts for airliners which is a really
thorny problem because you never know
what you're going to need to put onto
the airplane at which Airport you're
going to be at anyway ai is really good
at solving some kinds of complex
problems the other thing is that AI is
an essential aspect of a lot of
automation problems smart robotics
self-driven cars those by definition
have some sort of AI
you it would be basically impossible
otherwise I would say that most natural
language interface can be considered to
be AI programs so way back to Siri you
know if you have a an assistant who gets
a virtual assistant who gets to know you
better and better and can communicate
better with you and answer your
questions the way you're really
intending them
there's machine learning going on there
and it's an AI program oh here's a good
working model of artificial intelligence
I've been using this for several years I
was happy to see that Professor
journalist covets used it this year when
he was talking about trends and
artificial intelligence - the big
meeting for joint venture Silicon Valley
basically there are three kinds of
levels of tasks the most simple task is
sensing or detecting something so
there's a lot of programs for instance
threat detection or computer vision
where basically you're receiving some
sort of information over and over again
you get better and better at it the more
you do it if you put more analysis into
this then you're really comprehending
the situation beyond just sensing it
this would be things like natural
language analysis or threat analysis or
what did I have here new medical
diagnostics you're going over and over
again to understand the situation and
the more times you do it the better you
get full automation is where you really
get to this act stage and so you find
that with things like self-driving cars
smart power grid management intelligent
robots there are some automated stock
trading programs now that go faster than
people can go and you see all sorts of
areas in which this is applied what
we're going to apply a AI to in this
series or what are what I've taken the
liberty to call smart physic
systems you'll also see the word cyber
physical systems see PS what I'm talking
about is really well I get into that
first of all this is to introduce the
survey van your Goblin are you here I
don't see you okay so I had to research
assistants working with me the summer
daniyar in Mumbai of who is an
electrical engineering and Gollum in
Mumbai of who is in medical school and
just about to start his MBA program at
the Business School and we did a survey
to see the extent of progress that
companies in Asia have been making in
applying artificial intelligence to what
we're calling smart physical systems we
primarily surveyed startup companies but
we also looked at some relevant
developments and big companies so what
we mean by smart physical system is
first of all the program has to have
some sort of control element in it some
sort of control over a physical system
we weren't just looking at analytics
right you can do predictive analytics
about women machine is going to go bad
in a factory but unless there's some
element of automation involved it's not
really having control over the physical
system it does it is something that
implements some form of artificial
intelligence or autonomous
decision-making and they're really the
closer you get between the function of
the artificial intelligence and the
physical system control the more we were
interested in the company and of course
we were looking at companies that are
basically operated out of Asia or are
you know registered in Asia so that's
what we mean by smart physical systems
we used the CB insights lists of startup
companies as our primary source of
companies
only looked at companies that had
received funding in Asia in the last two
years we sorted the companies and
according to a various list of
categories we eliminated a lot of the
character categories that CBN sites have
from there we really hand-picked each
company according to the standards we
showed on the previous page and tried as
much as we could to avoid companies that
are purely analytic although it's
sometimes very delicate to tell the
difference in agricultural technology
there's quite a few companies that are
using sensors to measure the moisture in
the ground and crop growth and they will
tell you how much fertilizer to put out
or how much pesticide to put out on the
basis of what's going on meter by meter
in the field if they just tell you to do
it is it really controlled system or not
so as you know it's kind of a delicate
thing and I can't promise that we were
always accurate and following that but
we also examined market research reports
about cyber-physical systems other news
sources about Asia business we looked at
the portfolio companies of Asia focused
venture capital firms and other
institutional investors and we also had
you know some similar information that
we could get about what the big
companies are doing from their own
company press releases so that's the
kind of methodology that we used when we
were evaluating these companies we were
trying to look at their technical
innovation was it really something
different that it have a WOW factor in
it was it something that's just sort of
oh my goodness here's another one or was
it really something that was kind of
this is different how distinct was it
from other companies that are kind of
sort of competing and also we looked at
their so they're kind of recent
publicity what kind of missions they
were getting in the press these days you
get information all
all over the place right so what did we
find first of all these are the areas
that we looked at we divided things up
into three basic huge things smart
machines IOT systems and smart processes
now of course there's a lot of overlap
especially by the time you get down to
smart processes most of these we
eliminated because the real developments
were covered by the smart machines now
my research assistants did not do a
survey on smart assistants on virtual
assistants but we do have a company
coming up in a couple of weeks it has
kind of an interesting new approach to
virtual assistants so that's the ones
that we used we found companies that
sort of generally fit into our domain of
interest right robotics companies we
looked at over 200 startup companies and
out of those we found that there were
really only about thirty that are twenty
seven that were using artificial
intelligence for the robotic control we
looked at eighty eight drone companies
and found eight of them that fit our
criteria we looked at a hundred and
fifty autonomous driving
you know autonomous vehicle companies
and found about twenty four of them so
that's the smart machine domain in the
IOT systems domain we looked at over 200
companies and came up with about 30 that
were really kind of fitting the criteria
we were looking at and if you go on to
the smart processes that weren't already
covered by the smart machines we looked
at about a hundred and eighteen
companies and we picked about seventeen
so you're seeing on average something
that's about 1/7 to one-tenth of the
companies that we looked at really we're
using artificial intelligence for system
control which is quite a lot remember
this is only Asian companies this does
not include US companies it does not
include companies in Europe and you know
for comparison angel list showed 4731
artificial intelligence startup
companies worldwide back in June so we
looked at 770 companies just in Asia and
you know moving into the domains of what
we were looking at industrial robotics
has been a major area of strength for
companies in Asia for a long time
especially Japan has been a very strong
producer of industrial robots they still
account for 52 percent of the world
market and the this graph shows where
the robots are shipped to so notice the
remarkably high growth rate in Asia of
where the recipient country is one of
the one of the countries in Asia much
faster growth in terms of installed
robots than in the US or in the EU
so why the first thing is the increase
in Chinese labor costs so China still
has a lower number of robots per 10,000
factory workers than we do in the United
States and they intend to change that by
2025 so they're aiming right now in
China it's about 49 per 10,000 workers
49 robots per 10,000 workers whereas in
the US it's about 80 they intend to have
a hundred and fifty per 10,000 workers
which is on par with Japan or Korea by
2025 the main providers of robots in
Japan two of them are Japanese companies
phonic which is the old gorilla for
factory robots right when you see the
giant robe
that are putting together automobiles in
the factory those are finite robots
almost well some of them are not some of
them are Kawasaki robots and others and
Yaskawa which is also a big robotics
company but ABB and Luka were the other
two robotics companies that were
supplying things into China and a
Chinese company bought cuca in 2017 so
the Chinese are definitely developing
their domestic base of robot producers
80% of the robots that are in China are
produced by joint ventures between
Chinese companies and foreign companies
so as with other domains this is kind of
what you see which starts out with joint
ventures and then the domestic industry
kicks off the other demand that's really
driving advanced technologies and
robotics are a need for rapid
programming and self learning by the
robot the old way to program a robot was
for numeric control the Japanese were
really good at this but the programs are
incredibly inflexible and so if you
wanted to change over the line to make
something a little bit different you had
to reprogram the robot and you had to
test it out and this took a long time so
there are this changeover for small
batch manufacturing really makes rapid
programming essential also there are
some items like picking up different
size packages and sorting them in a
warehouse that you really can't do with
the old kind of robotic numeric numeric
control of the robots so that's one of
the things that's driving advanced
technologies another thing driving
advanced technologies and robotics are
what are now called cobots where the
robot and the person are working
alongside each other often around the
same table cobots are much smaller
they're typically much cheaper and the
big thing
is that they are flexible they're
intended to physically interact with the
human and safety of course is a huge
issue in this the co bot was invented
about 1996 here in the US and the big
manufacturers in Japan were late fanuc
did not start making cobots until about
2015 or 2016 so you know if you're
really successful in something be
careful about the next paradigm of
technology that's to come but the co
bots are really driving growth now and
phonic has a CB 10 robotic arm that is
growing it you know market growth is
doing extremely well the other thing
that's happening in the already
industrialized countries is refitting
the existing base with new capabilities
machine vision computer vision or other
kinds of capabilities again that will
improve efficiency improve safety and
also enable this kind of easier
changeover so that kind of things
happening one of the most interesting
companies in this space is a Japanese
company called Moo gene which makes a
robot controller basically the box that
controls the robot and it uses deep
learning to replace human teaching of
the robot with automated planning and so
they have a slide that claims to reduce
the time it takes to integrate a new
robot into the system from a year to
about two weeks which is a major savings
they were founded in 2011 kind of nice
to see a joint u.s. and Japan group
founding a company they've received over
300 million so far the most impressive
thing is every year they're growing 2.5
times right 258 compound annual growth
rate
ever since the first year they were in
operation 2012 it's this controller is
widely applicable to different robots
it's already being deployed by a Chinese
company in Shanghai in one of its
biggest warehouses JD dot-coms warehouse
is really kind of similar to something
that FedEx would be doing here or Amazon
would be doing here and this picking
boxes and putting them into the right
place to ship them to the right place
that's exactly what their system is
doing Muji and received the emerging
leader award in a program that I'm the
chair of the steering committee for the
japan-us Innovation Awards so we were
able to get the president of Muji mr.
takeno to come and speak here at
Stanford in July and I tried to get him
to come to this too but he said we'll
wait until next year okay well anyway
we're going ahead with the series but
Muji is a very interesting company and
we'll talk to one of their competitors
in this series drones so that was the
second kind of major type of smart
machine and here is one in which China
absolutely dominates the world market so
DJI this startup company from China had
72 percent of the world market in 2017
and then basically they bought out the
drone share from 3d robotics so they're
now at about 75 percent of the world
market two other companies are
noticeable in terms of world market
share and now the u.s. is out so China
definitely dominates the civilian market
worldwide for drones DJ I'm makes drones
that are more than a thousand dollars
and also less than a thousand dollars
and their dominance is really in the the
sector above a thousand dollars the
driver of
in China is last mile delivery because
this is a great leapfrog opportunity if
you have a weak transportation system
where it takes three hours to get from
one side of Shanghai to the other
having the drone take your package
across town look start to start to look
a lot more you know economical so the
the combination of sort of a difficult
infrastructure plus as we'll see good
regulation and you know technology
advancement is really allowing the
companies to do a lot more to use drones
for delivery this other Chinese company
we hang shows a specific way in which
this is really moving into advanced
areas they got a 1 billion dollar order
for a passenger sized drone that can a
person can ride in in order to transport
organs that will be used for transplant
and this is faster quicker it's a lot
easier than having a team of five people
have to you have to have a a pilot along
with the the person who's watching the
the heart beating they're partnering
with the US company called lung
technology to deliver this the most
recent information that I can get is
that it's still under development it's
still not happening yet but the the
order came in in 2016 and they partnered
with lung biotech in 2017 the government
regulations are kind of favoring China
in regard to the development of drones
the first big problem is that in the
u.s. you don't just have one set of
regulations you've got different
regulations for every state and you may
have different regulations for different
cities inside an area the u.s. is still
in the early stages of trying to develop
a comprehensive air control system and
meanwhile
the caac which is the equivalent of the
FAA is not really giving people a hard
time as long as you don't fly them at
night and don't fly them in a high wind
but because of the kind of slowness in
Japan JD is actually testing in stones
out in Thailand and Indonesia
so regulation if you're you know can
slow things down
interestingly enough in China Ella dot
me which is Ali Baba's food delivery
group God approval that just this year
to test
drone delivery in a large industrial
zone not just over anybody's house but
it's a large industrial zone inside
China one other point about the
government rolls a lot of Chinese AI
looks like it's going for military
application including autonomous weapon
systems and autonomous weapons delivery
systems this is not anything you know
there's no secrets here this is all out
of the news you can read it and what
they seem to be doing is the drones that
they're making for their own military
they're also selling to other countries
because the Americans and the Israeli
made drones are too expensive so five
million dollars for a system that the US
company would charge 100 million for ok
that's a business opportunity anyway the
government roles have kind of favored
drone development in China now I think
an interesting company that sort of weak
on the AI from sector but it's an
interesting company is called share
craft and basically this is a drone
that's being used for crop dusting there
are drones in France like this there are
drones being made in the US like this
but what this one is really good at is
dealing with a large area and a small
amount of time it has a cost advantage
over traditional farming
over traditional approaches and
especially in China one person dries
buys the drone system and the neighbors
all use it right they work out the
business arrangement of that among
themselves this company is planning to
expand to Japan because quote Japanese
farmers are used to technology okay
which is interesting considering most of
the farming population is probably over
65 years old in Japan but they have
already got their plans to move to Japan
for rice production and yeah the company
is based in Guangzhou it was founded in
I think 2014 and that's the one set of
money that they've got I think they're
already revenue positive the third area
of smart machines was automobiles so
here we're talking about the
self-driving cars and the u.s. is
clearly in the lead in terms of how many
hours of driving time self-driving cars
already have on the road I mean they're
just way ahead of everybody else in
terms of the numbers of hours that have
been driven and also I think that the AI
capabilities of the American firms are
probably in the lead one of the lead
scientists and Baidu said that we
basically have to buy our hardware from
the Americans so the chips the computer
chips that are doing the AI processing
or coming from the US but China is
really coming up fast
there was a Forbes article in May that
predicted that China would deploy
self-driving cars in a major way before
the US would they pointed out the
massive investment in artificial
intelligence that's going on in China
they pointed out that it's easier to get
government approval in China than here
to test out autonomous driving they
pointed out that Chinese people trust
autonomous driven cars
lot more than Americans do there was
some big survey numbers reported
something like 67 or 68 percent of the
Chinese people they survey trusted
autonomous driven cars and the number
was like 2x the the rate of trust in the
United States and there are fewer
concerns about ethical issues so
everybody knows the old horse you're in
the self-driving car where you know
something happens and you have to hit
the old person in the street or you have
to hit the kid on the sidewalk people
worry about that kind of thing less in
China than they do here where the social
what according to the article the the
the sense that what's important for the
greater group is the greater need so
it's a relatively clear-cut principle
where as we get all kind of funneled up
with things and also there's prediction
for increasing need in China as the
population in China ages right the
one-child policy is going to cause a
sharp move up in the age of the
population and one other reason that was
not mentioned in this article but was
mentioned in a different source referred
to the speed with which 5g communication
networks are rolling out in China a lot
of the intelligence is not just the car
it's how the car connects to the
communication infrastructure the
information infrastructure around it and
China's doing a better job of rolling
out 5g than we are again you got a lot
of local people who just don't want an
antenna every couple of hundred yards on
the street own the most interesting
thing in autonomous driven cars that's
different that's happening in China
though is the Apollo platform open
source platform for autonomous vehicle
software development this is applicable
to any kind of an automobile in
principle this is a huge change in the
car industry everything up to now in the
car industry has been closed the api's
for software to fit into the hardware
system do not transfer from a Toyota to
a GM to afford right it just can't
happen but with this they've got 116
partners in this project including Ford
and Hyundai and Bosch and these are
giving them access also to an awful lot
of data about the car performance and
and what people are doing so it's level
four of the five automate automation
levels which means it's almost
completely the car is doing everything
and Udacity is already partnered with
this group to provide online training
for the developers writing in this
language so this could really change the
automobile industry if you have an open
source platform for software development
who gets to do iTunes for the car right
the equivalent this is this is
definitely going to be interesting
they're already partnering with a
ride-sharing service in Chongqing and a
minibus system in China they've got
plans to launch in Japan with Softbank
in 2019 so you're also seeing
internationalization here too
Baidu is one of the first companies in
China that's really starting to spin-off
entrepreneurs kind of like Fairchild did
in the United States 4050 years ago
where for various reasons people are
leaving Baidu and starting their own
company and so we have at least three
competing autonomous driven companies
that came out of Baidu look how much
money these companies have raised so
Pony dot AI which has an office here in
Silicon Valley is the first one I could
find
they spun off in 2016 and they've
already raised two hundred and fourteen
million dollars so I think they're
probably a certified unicorn by this
point Roadstar dot a I spun off in 2017
and has raised 130 million and the other
one Jing Qi spun off in 2017 they didn't
raise a hundred million because they've
had a bad lawsuit with Baidu and that
has been settled because the person who
started the company has now left the
company and the company still exists so
Jing Qi is still around and they're
still developing these things okay this
is competition
this is China so that was the smart
machines if we look a little bit at
industrial IOT what we're really talking
about is the interconnection of machines
not so much the smart machines
themselves but how they all interconnect
and can be synchronized through the
cloud of the 22 companies that we found
for our survey seven of them were in
China six in Japan four in India for in
Israel and one in South Korea the real
market drivers if you're in a big
company the way to sell this to your
company is how to predict and present
malfunctions and do more efficient
maintenance scheduling and show how much
money you'll save by scheduling the
maintenance when you really need it
that's the killer application for now
but really improving the whole
efficiency of the system is definitely
part of this so that you may have a
really fully autonomous factory Europe
is actually ahead of both the US and
Asia in regard to the level of
automation across the factory and it's
not surprising because another name for
this industrial IOT is industry 4.0
which came out of turn
right the whole idea came from there and
some of the key factories in Asia that
are fully automated are actually German
subsidiary factories in China so anyway
that's industrial IOT and I think the
interesting company here is a joint
venture created by two Giants and a
start-up so phonic and Hitachi got
together with one of Japan's rare
unicorns and maybe the first AI unicorn
is certainly the first AI unicorn in
Japan preferred networks and the three
of them announced at the beginning of
this year this new joint venture company
that has been operational since April
and the company intelligent edge system
is supposed to be the intermediary
between the cloud and the edge devices
whether it's a machine tool or a robot
or you know some sort of the cart moving
things around inside the warehouse right
it's supposed to serve as that interface
I couldn't find anything since the joint
venture announcement so it's a
fascinating idea but I'm not exactly
sure where it is maybe they just haven't
put their website out yet the president
came from Hitachi and it's interesting
to see how what they were bringing to
the table so finally brought the robot
strengths right and also machine tools
and Hitachi is very famous for control
systems that's the software behind the
Shinkansen in Japan and also other
operational technology and preferred
networks brought the AI and fascinating
because preferred network says now worth
about 1.2 billion 1.3 billion and it's a
brand new company been around five or
six years incidentally there are speaker
next week
so we have preferred networks fellow
coming from Tokyo to speak in our
session next Thursday
moving on to smart built cities and
buildings so worldwide this is supposed
to be a high-growth sector what's it
really involving what's really in a
smart city what's really in a smart
building there has been I think a lot of
Technology driven bad solutions
I saw smart house models in 1995 they're
really stupid I don't want to live in a
house like this time to myself sometimes
and on a city level - there's been all
sorts of projects as early as 2012 Asia
was really taking the lead
there were pilot projects going on in
Japan and in South Korea and in 36
cities in China and China had already
announced plans to have 200 pilot smart
city projects within the next few years
so by 2020 or so the early drivers of
smartness and buildings and in sit at a
city level would be energy efficiency
environmental friendliness right
transportation improvements but more
recently one of the big drivers is
public safety and there was a very
severe feature article in The Economist
a couple of months ago about the state
of surveillance in China which is
extremely advanced because they're not
only identifying people they're
identifying behavior patterns and
analyzing behavior patterns and okay so
you see the public safety angle on this
but of course we worry about things like
privacy and and whether my version of
safe behavior matches the government's
version but still the if you look at the
individual cities not
national government investments but the
individual city investments the top five
Singapore Tokyo London New York London
again
I don't know how that happened and then
Shanghai I think London was number three
after Tokyo apologize for that but yeah
so I think the interesting company here
is a company called Quan Chi group or a
group of companies this is a classic
Asian model where a person founds a
company that eventually becomes a family
of company and so this person sort of
becomes the patriarch you see this in
Japan with the KDOT so you see this in
Korea with the chair ball you know
Samsung Group is the Lee family and so
Quan Chi is all kind of started by this
person named warping view and mr. Liu
has been called the Chinese L on Musk
partly because he invests and similar
crazy things they have a space
exploration company and yet one of the
things that's real business is they
signed an agreement just this year with
the Shanghai security service company to
make smart helmets that would in use
meta materials and also IOT infused
camera systems and so most likely this
will be used with the smart police force
I hope and there was no other details
mentioned but people were expecting to
see the path that's coming out pretty
soon so another thing that they did just
this summer was to partner with XI who
knew energy transportation development
and now they're trying to develop an
internal framework for a very you know
new energy vehicles and they did this by
forming the 50-50 joint venture so you
have an umbrella company now with lots
of different companies kind of
underneath that all of which are still
small startup companies but you hear
about these people in the news there
than coming so general trends how do you
tie all this together artificial
intelligence is a very hot topic and I
think that the investments in the Asian
countries have been more aimed at these
physical systems control than just
purely analytics
I think the purely analytic companies
maybe are still ahead in the United
States with regard to the massive
investments in artificial intelligence
though
China's way ahead of everybody else you
may know that the amount not just
artificial intelligence but the amount
of venture capital invested in China
last year was almost the same amount as
invested in the United States and the
growth rate has been a drastic rise so
China has stated that AI is a national
priority and it's going to be on parity
China will be on parity with the US by
2020 and will be the world leader by
2030 so not to be outdone the South
Korean say will be in the top four by
and so they've invested two billion in
government money in artificial
intelligence research and development
the Japanese say I market is much bigger
the market size is is pretty huge
already right for artificial
intelligence including analytics they're
predicting it to grow from 34 billion
dollars to over 750 billion dollars
within 15 years and out of that
transportations going to account for 30
or 40 percent of self-driving cars now
with regard to the other aspect of
growth though separate from investment
you have to consider talent the u.s. is
still in the lead but there's a lot of
people who are getting educated here and
then going back to China
one of the people in one of those Baidu
spin-off companies had worked for Tesla
Motors and Google before going back to
China and you know there are strong
educational programs that are developing
across Asia both in the basic math and
in the computer science that is
necessary in artificial intelligence the
area that the US has had the lead in has
been English language processing it kind
of makes sense but I think that if if
you can process double byte code as well
as English you know and you can really
get the semantics right for Chinese and
Japanese you can own the world in terms
of natural language processing still the
u.s. is pretty far in the lead in that
regard Google translates already works
for 120 languages so the subtitle for
this series is will Asia take the lead
okay I tried to get people in the door
with that title what I'm really
interested in are more interesting
questions like what areas are the Asian
businesses and Asian governments going
to target how is this going to develop
differently in Asia than it is in the US
how will Asia develop the policies and
the institutional frameworks to support
this kind of innovation it will and
because of this sort of different
development new opportunities are going
to open up here and this is the ultimate
question is what's in it for us and I'm
hoping that both for students and for
our visitors from the valley there'll be
some really interesting and exciting
content I'm really looking forward to
mr. Maruyama next week from preferred
networks and we will start to look at
this from next week
that's my prepared remarks from today
I'll be happy to answer some questions
thanks for your attention
floors open I'll go
go ahead Walter yeah I didn't really
have a chance to look at the medicine
and very frankly the US has some really
strong companies in this regard
intuitive robotics has been putting AI
into their stuff and I haven't found the
killer companies in Asia but I think
that's partly because we didn't really
look at medicine in our survey this
summer this was really recent work just
over the last couple of months good
medicine companies we should connection
with human does it actually would be a I
give you the answers you know I said
about 20 very high qualified low the
doctors that sit behind the machine but
you also have very very powerful clear
so that you keep you know assistants
attraction very intelligent this ask you
more specific questions based on
information that they're feeling it
right can give you answers for the bell
curve the ring may not actually watching
it and if anything ms or they feel that
you know that's not quite right or they
pick on something
then they have to be jumping okay so
that's a really interesting company I
think mobile health and things like
FinTech is also driven by mobile
applications is really important now it
wouldn't fit into our survey because
it's not a smart physical system there's
no control element in it right you get
the advice back from the doctor but
including a recommendation to go to a
pharmacy and get something right but my
point is there's no control element
where it's controlling a physical device
the interface yeah so that's why you
know and thank you I hope you don't mind
me pointing that out but that's exactly
why we tried to to keep it down to the
small number of companies that we looked
at but uh we should I wish we had had
time to look at medicine
go ahead companies although if it was
control over the control over the very
equipment to make the chip companies
we've looked at it I have about four
pages of AI chip companies that we're
starting a big survey that's a year long
this year and the big companies are
doing it the small companies are doing
it this is a huge area a lot of
artificial intelligence is being
processed on graphic processing chips
cause they're already faster than the
old CPU chips but if you do it
specifically for a type of artificial
intelligence problem you can achieve
another 100x in speed so a lot of the
self-driving car companies have got the
chips that they're trying to develop
this
is a really hot topic we didn't do it in
this survey but it's a it's a really
good interesting topic go ahead so like
in the u.s. there have been a lot of
debates about like privacy and how data
can be used like with Facebook
especially recently how has that played
out in China and do you think like the
privacy issues in the US will kind of
pulls back the kind of AI development um
I think that on the one hand the
government has always had a much more
top-down view into what's going on at an
individual level in China you know the
the famous Great Firewall of China if it
hadn't been for the Great Firewall of
China the internet probably could have
not gotten to that country and I've been
in you know I've had troubles with the
firewall when I'm in China and I'm
trying to send files around right
because I don't have a domestic address
but I think that the people who are
really ahead in that are the Europeans
and I will tell you one thing that
happened to me just the other week that
tells me how the world will develop I
went to a startup company in Mountain
View that has a nice level analytic I
program really interesting company and I
said well are you worried about privacy
and the CEO said to me oh we're gdpr
compliant the general data privacy
regulation is the European Union's
privacy law and by moving ahead with
that standardization they're likely to
be the standard setter if you go back 30
years the Japanese spent a whole lot of
money developing high-definition
television and quietly the Japanese had
an analogue standard quietly the
Europeans were developing a standard for
digital TV and so guess who won
so I frankly think that this is another
area where
somebody's going to take the lead I
think the Europeans are taking the lead
in this I think they're probably going
to solve the problems that we're all
wondering what to do about and that's
good
that pulls the world forward and should
help us and also economies in Asia move
forward in a productive way so yeah I
think that watching what each other does
and trying to learn from each other is
the essence of international business I
think in China it as an American I feel
like it's very intrusive situation but
that's a feeling I think that when you
come to a business proposition
people will find a way to make money and
will find a way to get the technology
forward and will find a way to solve the
problem somehow so I'm basically
positive about the future but we've got
a lot to go and I think that a lot of
the people who are developing the
programs haven't thought enough about
the ethic side and the privacy side and
other issues if you're a technology
developer that kind of stuff makes you
feel like it's slowing you down when
really it keeps you from going down
rabbit trails that are not leading
anywhere is the way I would look at it
the good ethical standards should be
very helpful thank you important
question go ahead
would be very interesting because the
demographics in China with an aging
population I think China very interested
in you might say things such as certain
products yeah and those patents are
expiring there are actually quite a few
companies many in the stealth mode that
are
you know being starting up and in terms
of just the certificate bothers young
but the other thing that was interesting
I think that has happened in the last
few months for the nor the last year
let's say in China is the second thing
you were talking about with just AI
chips yeah and what happened to last
year I think is with the u.s. ban on
Zeki acquired chips from the US yeah you
know Beijing kind of recognized there is
a a weakness over there in terms of the
lack of the chip technology yeah
goodness so I think immense amount of
interest it's now being development of
next-generation ships which could go
beyond your years
I really I think you're absolutely right
and I think that that's what happens
when you try to put a brake on people
decide we got to do it by ourselves and
from the last year is that after the
Hong Kong stock of change that actually
chained their listing rules is that the
biotech company even without any cells
but if you can have like like some proof
about your pipeline because yet admitted
by the FDA or CFCs FDA certain few that
you can get listed so start from the
like 2017 and a lot of customers coming
here but and as for the AI I think so in
China the more company with AI the
calcareous the health care services
polished which they actually click this
newest data and use the AI to analysis
but for the draw company like biotech I
I don't think the never be married are
because you know thoughtful for them
like research it's a very long process
so in stealth using AI they prefer use
the licensing strategy but remember AI
is now being applied to problems that
really can't be done in the other way so
the whole idea of personalizing medicine
according to someone's genomic makeup
you know that's something without the
computing power you can't do and I think
that another area that the drug
companies are using is analytic it
doesn't fit my smart physical systems
but they're doing analysis of the
possible risk and return profiles of
different applications of the compounds
and it's kind of a fancy way of doing
future scenario forecasting because it
takes a hundred million dollars to put
something through clinical trials for a
particular application so you want to
put it in the most likely application
first right
that's going to be the best business
first and the drug companies are using
that kind of analytical program behind
what they're up to
now in pharma you've got some
interesting work going on in India but
the Japanese and the Chinese have not
really been doing that much advanced
drug development they've largely been
making the drug companies have been
making their money from over-the-counter
products and paying the licensing fees
to the big American and European drug
companies how long that lasts I don't
know and I do think that you're going to
get personalization of Medicine and that
will bring in AI into this picture
good excellent and it's interesting
about the different requirements for
listening on the Hong Kong exchange to
that we'll see what kind of stimulus
effect that has other comments you first
I saw your hand first
proving clinical trial okay process
I think it's focusing on a guy because
usually in efficient what is that going
to happen it's going to be here at the
fact week October 15 we usually put the
V lab programs in our e-mail
announcements and especially the ones
that will be at the Faculty Club we've
been happy to cooperate so venture lab V
lab does really interesting programs
with some entrepreneurs and investors
and a couple of outside experts for each
program that they do should be very
interesting
I saw your hand see it as the evolution
of the automobile industry where the
telephone did this when app when really
Apple came out with the iPhone as an
open standard right and the their
version of the smartphone really changed
things you know that was the Palm Pilot
there was no stuff the BlackBerry before
Apple but Apple had the market clout to
really get third-party developers to use
their platform and I think that between
by doing Tesla's there they got enough
clout that this may change the way
software is developed for cars period
not just AI when you have an open
platform that becomes a really powerful
thing very disruptive good go ahead
so you mentioned many different and I
assume that would include critical
infrastructure away in the transport
doesn't that leave City including the
exports to Morris and in light of this
do you think there are any functions
that will never be fully automated okay
those are two questions and the first
question the good news is that people
are aware of this risk and I've seen
articles in the Japanese news for the
last four or five months that are all
about how secure are IOT devices and
really worried about that's the way
you're going to hack into the whole
system right you get in through
somebody's toaster and you know take
down the entire computer network so I
think that we're moving forward in that
regard that's a race that will never end
because as soon as you develop a way to
deal with it
the bad people develop something else
but it's also something that people
don't stop using just because it's a
problem so I'm pretty positive about
that I'm glad that people are more aware
of it than they were until recently
because this is an area that could
really be absolutely horrible the other
thing about what doesn't really become
automated so we've done these surveys
about different kinds of aspects of AI
for a number of years now and one thing
that comes out is that when it's a
really important decision people always
want a person in the background so like
what you were mentioning the doctor
standing behind the AI you always want a
person kind of being the ultimate
decision-making authority low level
decisions are the ones that get
automated low level tasks are the ones
that get automated so I think to a
certain extent executive decisions are
always going to keep
at the top of the pyramid and the other
thing that does not automate well I
don't care how good the language
interface is customer service and that's
just something where I I hope I'm not
just showing my age but I don't like
automated telephone systems and so I
think that at the end of the day people
want to interact with other people
somehow and where will they always want
to do that one is customer service the
other is a kind of area in which you
really need off-the-wall creative
thinking because basically AI always
works by analyzing what's been given
even though there are predictive
algorithms it's a tiny bit beyond
deductive reasoning right it's a little
bit inductive but not much and so when
you want to have something that is just
absolutely a bizarre new idea people are
going to do that and so I think as the
roots of innovation people will always
be there that's another good question
others if not we've got some
refreshments outside and I'd be very
happy to talk with each and every one of
you in a more informal way thanks again
see
you